I'm gonna be honest since I since I
started drinking during the holidays
they've gotten a lot easier Oh little
Grinch
this looks toxic it's pretty smooth
smells like kool-aid man so yes is there
even alcohol in this it just tastes like
sugar and regrets like my mistake I'd
probably give this to a toddler now I'll
get you through your grandma asking you
a million times like we should we should
make a baby so if you're having like a
Christmas party with all your friends
maybe in a garage maybe there's a beer
pong table around people are drinking
these usually like five out of five five
out of five ridges okay nice nice
how do you feel about that you have to
dream you like this it looks so happy
and then you taste it and it's like
would you feel confident ordering these
for her yeah as long as we split the
check and you still break her heart
Hammond's me man her people hurt people
everyone has that like sweet aunt I'm
going to do a 1/2 mall Santas because I
don't think it's a Christmas drink it's
not a Christmas drink
this is this isn't you found on
Pinterest oh but it looks like
pepto-bismol time gone on fashion runway
we give this like a ten attitude shrink
is part of the ambience of the drink is
part of the presentation Matt I am NOT
yeah yeah holy hell that was strong
that one's got the food our Unabomber
right now that way also the mint reminds
me of toothpaste so I feel like you
could drink this in the morning okay
should we talk about your drinking in
the morning my fellow DG's would be like
yeah girl let's get drunk and it's just
like a bunch of like peppermint schnapps
you know these drinks are so fun because
I feel like this is something you could
probably make like with your family it's
like an activity yeah I'll give it to
candy canes I I give it three because
the presentation was flawless 2.5 girls
think it's a mixer okay so a single lady
deserves this drink he does cuz a lot of
ways out there ruining lives oh yeah
that's just wine with fruit man mm-hmm
that is grownup apple juice when I drink
at my I'm not upset I'm single I'm like
a sexy person this is the Christmas
morning drink oh I can I can get on you
you don't wrap some presents with this
you open some prunes yes